[Música]
é muito bom muito bom muito bom
qual a responsabilidade depois a gente
pega e fala dá um nó show nem a gente
fica assim naquela responsa também tem
uma trajetória também para contar pra
vocês ou e se eles tenham também tem
para com 12 anos eu levei o meu primeiro
fora com 16 o meu primeiro na bunda
aos 18 perdíamos economia comprando o
avestruz master
aos 24 pedir 120 mil reais de
investimentos da finep é a minha
primeira startup seu gabriel então a
saber também tem uma história para
contar
e hoje eu sou professor da universidade
federal do mato grosso e trabalho com o
ensino de ciências
mas não existindo ciência tradicional
aquele que você entra no quadro x
quadrado mais y quadrado gols de
cuadrado não a gente precisa reformular
a e pensar numa nova forma de ensinar
ciência de transformar através da
ciência e quando me oferecendo esse tema
metamorfose de uma energia uma coisa a
um processo de repensar então o que essa
metamorfose é a metamorfose acho que o
projeto é muito bom só de dentro para
fora nem com apupam um filho mas nós
somos humanos
nem nós precisamos um outro modelo de
transformação e nossa metamorfose ela
vem de fora para dentro o que quero
dizer com isso eu quero dizer que nós
humanos nos moldamos reagimos sentimos
pensamos aquilo que nos toca aquilo que
vem de encontro com a gente e toca nos
nossos sentimentos mais profundos nos
sonhos dos nossos ideais nos nossos
objetivos
e aí eu sempre fui um cara que vê muita
porrada não fiz muita pensa nunca deu
tudo errado
aos 30 anos meu orientador de doutorado
não vou aguentar mais
imagina se eu pegar um título já
feliz pronto para a indústria das
realizações e pontos eu só vai pra baixo
aí você fala assim agora perdi o título
não vamos correr mas já pensou eu vou
fazer mas qualquer questão a questão é a
gente se molda aprendi com a realidade
que a gente está inserido
aprendi com as porradas e é essa porrada
estela essas transformações que causa a
nossa metamorfose é isso que nos
transforma e aí eu acho que eu fiquei
anos pensando no modelo de como
sintetizar então todas essas
experiências tanto negativas ou
positivas como trabalhar essas essas
várias vertentes e chegar no objetivo e
sem fazer nenhum merchant essa espiral é
pra você
e olha só que legal onde ela começa
começa lá no cliente
mas veja bem se você observar os grandes
vultos da história as grandes pessoas
que fizeram transformações
ela se moldaram a partir de uma
realidade que os tocavam um exemplo por
exemplo de alexandre o grande o que
motivou esse cara sair da macedónia e
até a índia levando 60 mil pessoas
ele acordou um belo dia falou vou
conquistar o mundo o fazer a função das
culturas eles não alguma coisa me chama
esse cara alguma coisa tocou nele que
ele olhou nos interesses um mundo a ser
conquistado e eu vou conquistar lo pensa
inverno 2011 mas uma caixa de charutos
um telégrafo
mas por que ele foi abençoado com o dom
divino nem o criador colocou a mão sobre
foto vai mudar o mundo não as
experiências que você está sujeito às
experiências que o moldam a de tudo que
você vivenciou é que vai causar essa
metamorfose é isso que vai acender você
aquele desejo aquela energia aquele site
aquele cinto transformador mas pra isso
você precisa aprender também fazer as
perguntas certas
olha o colega do lado olha o teto ao
piso pergunta o que pode ser mudado
tua ficar num modelo equacionar a
vivenciar uma zona de conforto que
esquecemos de fazer as perguntas que
transforma as perguntas que mudam
se você faz sim à pergunta certa 50% o
problema foi resolvido
olha a pessoa do lado literalmente e
pergunte o que você poderia fazer para
melhorar a vida dela se ela tem algum
problema que você consegue resolver
é claro que se você tem um em cima disso
também é bom não tem problema nenhum
o ct é esse tipo de abordagem
veja bem se a gente começar a pensar nos
recessos criativos de transformação e
pegar a época do renascimento
o que a gente não tem uma explosão de
gênios
onde foi parar a atividade dos cafés
parisienses fervilhavam de pensadores o
sôr de ro trouxeram as grandes questões
que nos torna humanos nos tornam mágicos
né afinal que espécie tão bem sucedido
quanto nós somos bons em que há
problemas mas também somos bons e
solucioná los
e veja bem desses cafés fervilhava o
debate as pessoas conversavam tocava
ideia e o confronto dessas idéias trazer
o melhor resultado
e hoje nós perdemos um pouco dessa
habilidade nos esquecemos como fazer
essa transformação
o segundo ponto também a ideia pela
ideia é muito pouco
penso o seguinte nós somos cinco milhões
de pessoas
quantos gauss oilers mari por e as três
se perderam durante o processo durante
uma vida seja morar no lugar errado o
moral está no tempo errado não tem
acesso a uma boa educação a um morreu no
conflito religioso morreu numa guerra a
ocorrer uma guerra de gangues não sei
quantos e quantos gênios se perderam na
história simplesmente porque não
enxergar uma oportunidade de fazer
aflorar todo seu potencial
quantos de nós aqui quando nos deitamos
o nosso 4
de repente nos vem aquela nostalgia
aquela lembrança conta sim
uau estou com 40 50 60 anos o que eu fiz
o que eu poderia ter feito que já se
pegou ressentimento beleza então nós
vamos dar uma olhada para respirar
porque essa espiral é pra você olha só
esse cliente vai ser exatamente aquele
sentimento que vai despertar em você a
partir de uma visão de mundo
eu não sei eu não conheço vocês eu não
sei o que mexe com vocês mas eu vou
dizer o que mexe comigo o que mexe
comigo quando eu vou numa comunidade é
quando eu vou na floresta ou quando vou
no cerrado e vejo um potencial que
aquilo tem eu vejo uma planta imagine
aquela planta transformada numa faria
que vai ver um produto comercial
aquela casca que pode ser transformada
num piso o que emociona vocês o que mexe
com vocês o que toca vocês lá no fundo
disse que se emociona ver uma pessoa
doente que emociona é uma pessoa com
fome
a gente se emociona ver um problema de
trânsito
essa é a grande pergunta transformadora
que vai nascer ali porque quando você
conseguir responder o que mexe com você
começou aquela primeira etapa de esperar
o cliente porque agora você vai começar
a pensar em como realizar a sua visão
não há visão daquilo que mexe com você
coisa que só esses empresários beleza
que pensa em lançar um produto ótimo
quem pensa que ser professor é legal a
venda então são essas coisas essas
coisas mexem com vocês essas coisas
despertam seu potencial
essas coisas despertam que você tem de
melhor
então você já venceu a primeira etapa a
próxima etapa e agora é o que eu chamo
de imagem ar que a fusão das palavras
imaginação mas engenharia
você já imaginou que você quer agora
você vai gerar para isso acontecer
como disse uma ideia por mais brilhante
que seja é uma idéia mota
a ação ainda precisa ser construída
precisa ser transformada precisa ser
aplicada
e aí vêm as segundas às etapas da
espiral porque essa empresário teve um
insight viu uma visão de mercado uma
necessidade que não era preenchida
trabalhou criou aquele agora ele vai
inovar para colocar o produto no mercado
e ganhar sua margem de contribuição
quem quer ser professor mesmo caso em
que o cliente quer fazer mestrado
doutorado
quero ser empreendedor não importa como
você quer transformar o mundo essa
resposta só vocês só vocês são cá
responder a isso a minha visão de
transformar o mundo a minha metamorfose
foi olhar um problema sócio ambiental e
propor uma solução
mas o que eu percebi a começou o
professor orienta alunos
fazemos um trabalho de conclusão de
curso e o que a gente percebeu que
muitos desses trabalhos vão chegar a
lugar nenhum segundo nada em janeiro
bastava simplesmente criar um padrão
zinho para obter uma nota no final do
semestre se aprovado formar só que isso
é muito pouco um jipe safari um algo
mais
e aí eu não entendia muito bem esse
processo porque não tenha paixão o tc
porque compensa passando no transformar
até que eu comecei a perceber que quando
eu pegava se alunos levavam ele e
colocaram de frente para um problema
social bem como a questão tecnológica
uma questão de sustentabilidade
despertava o gatilho porque agora ele
entende o que ele estava fazendo porque
ele estava fazendo aquilo que haja uma
sinergia uma mágica uma coisa louca você
imagina o aluno vai trabalhar sábados de
manhã e horário não faz sentido pra ele
ele entrou no bar tomar medidas à meia
noite
esquece de comê e aço o relógio é um uma
coisa abstrata perdeu totalmente o
sentido e essa mata que a gente precisa
internalizar se queremos fazer realmente
uma metamorfose e começando hoje
começando agora começa o primeiro
pergunta
que mexe comigo que me transforma o que
faz eu ia lei o que faz com que uma
quatro horas por dia e levante voltou à
faculdade ou universidade a minha
metamorfose começa assim ver o meu
problema lá ver a floresta ver o cerrado
eo potencial que aquilo tenha
desperdiçado
então pra mim e nós também não faz
sentido de 45 hora tá bom
sáb e domingo que é isso
quanto você está disposto a matar pra
você atinge a sonda tabu fose veja bem
nada contra se você não abre mão do
churrasquinho no fim de semana ótimo
a conta se você não abre mão de domingo
12 horas por dia
ótimo nada contra você não abre mão do
som barzinhos à noite
ótimo é questão de escolha
qual o tamanho da sua metamorfose qual o
tamanho da mudança que você quer
o quanto você quer pacto quanto você
quer mudar o mundo o quanto você você
quer mudar você mesmo
os primeiros alunos etc de marcar uma
aula de sábado de manhã para o sono
posso nota semana pessoa no pós pessoa
posta o próprio times tanto aqui quanto
os dias realmente se destacaram se
destacar que foram muito hoje foi os que
entenderam esse processo entenderam a
realidade socioambiental que ele estava
em seriados promover uma mudança
trabalhar toda essa mudança se
transformar e levar essa solução pra
comunidade para tornar as pessoas
melhores pouquinho tem problema de
pouquinho em pouquinho de junho para
seguir junto com ele mais um pedacinho e
aí a gente consegue promover uma
transformação
então veja bem a metamorfose a
transformação aquilo que vêem bate mexe
com você e te abre uma realidade
abriu-se uma perspectiva que você olhar
o mundo de outro jeito
só você é capaz de dizer o que quer que
vai fazer isso com você
se você não sair daqui com essa pergunta
respondida
você perdeu seu tempo nessa palestra
porque a única mensagem que eu tenho que
passar e eu vou chegar mais importante é
expondo o que eu vejo o óleo que cho
pergunto mexe comigo a ponto de me
transformar porque lembre-se a
metamorfose não é de dentro para fora de
fora para dentro
você faz o cliente você trabalha nesses
clientes nesse site e nova pra fazer e
acontecer
esse é o processo e tentar certa minha
vida tem sido de errado nisso
eu olho o pé de castanha no texto uma
castanha de bonitinha não vejam buriti
eu vejo o substituto só por esse é o meu
cliente
essa é a minha voz é isso que mexe
comigo isso que me transforma isso que
faz a pular da cama todos os dias muito
cedo tem problema
agora se você novamente não entendeu que
esse processo
você vai cair numa zona de conforto numa
rotina uma estagnação a que pra você
todas as respostas são boas
você se acostuma com a paisagem tudo o
que você faz é viver um dia após o outro
após o outro após o outro uma seqüência
de pouca realização
isso não importa se na academia se isso
no trabalho se na universidade onde você
quer começar você pode começar agora
você pode abrir o aplicativo pode passar
o seu batom usando o smartphone e
perguntar eu posso fazer uma maquiagem
melhor que essa
isso não é uma transformação isso não te
promove se você tem esse desejo claro de
pensar como fazer melhor
depende se achou um lixo
depende de você acha que essa mensagem
mais importante
essa é a minha experiência isto eu
gostaria de compartilhar com você
e deixar com uma reflexão hoje vocês vão
ter suas casas vão sentar vão pensar e
não importa muita questão de idade não
alexandre pontos conquistou praticamente
todo 34 do mundo civilizado
aos 26 anos roberto em criou a rede
globo 60 albert einstein mudou nossa
percepção do espaço tempo aos 26
perceba que é não é questão de idade de
ter aqui ó dentro de você
ok ok tem capacidade de mudar o mundo
basta fazer a pergunta certa e se
questionar
olha para um lado olha o copo que você
está usando olha o celular que está
segurando o que eu posso fazer com isso
aqui é melhor um sapato uma roupa uma
sacola
eu só me lembro muito bem a questão da
sustentabilidade de copo pô
olhe para o copo não veja um copo vejo
uma oportunidade que eu posso fazer com
esse copa
como posso ter a sua mais um copo em
algo até um copo descartável coisa todo
mundo tem um desejo eu acho que o maior
problema hoje nós perdemos
acessibilidade em relação a esse desejo
nós esquecemos o que é que nos
transforma somos cercados bombardeados
por uma mídia por informação que nos
coloca naquela zona de conforto
trabalhamos um dia após a outra e
esquecemos aquilo que mais importante
que alimenta não só eu mas todos humanos
nossos sonhos dos nossos objetivos para
que a gente construa a grande poesia que
nós podemos porque isso nos molda
avançar
isso joga pra frente então é essa grande
eu acho que a melhor pergunta o que vai
provocar nossa metamorfose o que lá fora
vai mexer comigo e me transformar pensa
nisso hoje acho que essa mensagem
[Aplausos]
vocês são fantásticos e um obrigado
gente só fantástico uma honra
é uma honra estar aqui com vocês abraço